simplifique 4 al cuadrado elevado a 3
aplicaremos la propiedad que dice que el
producto si tenemos a por b por b
y elevó todo a n es lo mismo que ha
elevado a n por b
^ n se lo explicaré con un ejemplo
simple cuanto es a por b
cuanto es a por b elevado a 3 es igual a
a por b
eso es elevado a 1 por a por b es
elevado a 2 por a por bs elevado a 3
estamos multiplicando esta expresión por
sí misma tres veces según las
propiedades conmutativa y asociativa de
la multiplicación podemos cambiar el
orden si cambiamos el orden en el que
multiplicamos lo podemos escribir como
a por a por a por b por b por b hay tres
a es y tres veces esto queda ha elevado
a tres y estoy acá queda b elevado a
tres tenemos ha elevado a tres por b
elevado a tres funcionó espero que
entiendan porque esta propiedad funciona
ahora apliquemos la en el problema
tenemos cuatro al cuadrado por b elevado
a 3
eso significa que todos los componentes
en el producto están elevados a 3 así
que es igual a 4 elevado a 4
x al cuadrado elevado a 3 por b elevado
a 3 lo marcaré con color la potencia 3
el aire con fucsia hacia la potencia 3
en vez de multiplicar primero y luego
elevar a 3 primero los puedo separar y
luego elevar los a 3 y después
multiplicar hagamos eso y tratemos de
simplificar
cuanto es 4 elevado a 3
4 elevado a 34 elevado a 144 elevado a
12 16 luego multiplicamos 16 por 4 así
que 4 elevado a 3 es cuatro por cuatro
por cuatro y eso es 64 luego al cuadrado
elevado a tres según la propiedad del
producto de los exponentes es elevado a
dos por tres o elevado a seis
así que es ha elevado a 66 es dos por
tres y finalmente queda b elevado a tres
lo haré con otro color
sólo queda ve elevado a 3 y lo escribiré
aquí la expresión que 264 ha elevado a 6
b elevado a 3